the next question is from artisan ours
is a great idea because i love what i do
i found my passion i know what i want
but when it comes to selling finding the
right customers in spots right there
yeah um i think obviously we talked
about it last time around really
believing and your passion and and the
essence of sounds like in this business
you got a product then you need to find
out how do you connect the customs and i
think the world of digital media is a
great way to go and you can get
immediate feedback you know in real time
you could almost build products just in
time thousands of customers through
social media um that's the best way
honest if if you've got antennas social
anti to listen to your customers and
build and cause correct your product
strategy to meet their needs you're
going to probably have a great business
and your creates huge value just focus
on the value you're creating the problem
you're trying to solve from and continue
to be disruptive if you do that you're
onto a winner I love it to add I would
say all the greatest products that we've
come up with I designed selfishly like
there for me like I feel like why has
nobody done this and I'm frustrated and
I don't want to make it but nobody's
done it and I need it selfishly and so I
created and it it that's always been
like the biggest leak where I've tried
to like just look at a market and try to
figure out where is the best opportunity
because I wasn't deeply passionate about
it it never became something massive and
so this might be a curveball answer for
you guys but I always design products
around things that I love I feel I need
in my life and in terms of the promotion
this might even be a bigger curveball is
uh I don't do cold calling in Salesforce
and that kind of stuff my business model
is I kick up a ton of noise in my
industry right through using soldier
like I make a lot of noise in the
entrepreneurial world people know me you
may not know me in different worlds but
I kick up a lot of dust in my industry
and people notice and then people find
me and I find that that's way more
effective because you have ideal clients
coming to you as opposed to you reaching
out and trying to spam people or cold
call them and say please buy my product
they put you
much more powerful position so create
awesome products because you're making
something that you passions believe in
and then kick up a ton of noise in your
industry to get the right clients coming
to you yeah it's interesting and in the
last 10 years the world's turned upside
down because what what digital economy
and us running our lives from the palm
bar and the smartphones it means people
are back in control their lives they
build apps that meet their needs so it's
now the reality of most consumers
control their own destiny control the
root on the old days that kind of
companies coming up with ideas and other
spamming or sales and market and all
that stuff you know just an
interestingly from saje at about 75 cent
of our entrepreneurs who cut them to a
smile plugs have done their research
about the product before they even come
to our website so it's kind of cool now
that anybody whether it's tripadvisor's
holidays whatever your group is whatever
community is you guys are in control of
your lives and so what that means for if
you if you've got a great product
solving either a big big problem or just
solving your own frustrations if you put
it out there it's pretty likely people
will find it they'll find you're not
fine you're pretty good yeah I think
it's important to to surround yourself
with people who make you come alive and
if you have a powerful mission people
are gonna care about it right like
Stevens here with me he's a CEO a big
company right and you wouldn't think of
him as a CEO of a big company the ways
talking in this passionate entrepreneurs
and when I when I saw him speak I'd say
summit it's like I got to get this guy
in my channel we have to do something
together to lowes entrepreneurs you got
to find some way to get together and and
it wasn't there was never like a sales
pitch involved it was just he's it's not
a great message we have to get him
involved and I think if you can speak
with passion but what you're doing you
will start attracting people as long you
start making some noise about it yeah I
love it time but he's told me a lot of
sense and and through social mighty
talking a lot of sense and an EVO Jays
fan all good things so with social media
there's chemistry there's magic where
people come together form communities
and you know it's when we hire people as
well we have people got
passion the same energy the same belief
and you know it is more than just
business it's about making a difference
it's about following your passions and
many of you guys are out there following
what you think's a noble cause and we
applaud that the absolutely employed so
I think the world of digital has changed
everything and things that took years
happen in nanoseconds there I'm
community to come together and solve
problems together so that's a rich
territory for you to bring products to
market meeting needs of people out there
created value and building great
businesses